Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Quatre mètres carrés,
c’est à peu près la taille du tapis sur
lequel je me tiens devant vous ce soir.
Quatre mètres carrés, c'est l'espace
dédié à un réfugié dans un camp.
J'ai appris à voir le monde à travers
ces parcelles de mètres carrés.
Je m’appelle Rima Hassan
et mon monde est un camp.
Et pour comprendre d’où je viens
et qui je suis vraiment,
il faut saisir la croisée des chemins des
trois pays auxquels mon histoire est liée.
Je suis mes origines palestiniennes.
Je suis mon enfance syrienne.
Et je suis mon présent
de citoyenne française.
Ma famille paternelle est originaire
d’Acre, tout au nord de la Palestine,
du village d’al-Birweh,
et la famille de ma mère
est originaire de Salfit,
[à côté de] la ville de Naplouse,
en Cisjordanie.
En 1948, ils vont être installés
dans ce camp,
le camp de Neirab,
qui se trouve dans la banlieue d’Alep,
en Syrie.
Cette installation,
elle intervient suite
au grand exode palestinien,
qu’on appelle la Nakba,
la catastrophe en arabe.
À compter de cette date,
toutes les générations de ma famille
vont se succéder dans ce camp.
De mes arrière-grands-parents,
à mes grands-parents, à mes parents,
et à moi.
Moi, j’arrive à la quatrième génération.
Sur la photo, je ne ressemble pas
énormément à ma mère, mais c’est bien moi.
Je vais naître dans le camp de Neirab et
je vais y rester jusqu’à l’âge de dix ans.
Souvent, on me demande quel est
le souvenir que je garde de ce lieu.
Et paradoxalement, je réponds :
« L’insouciance. »
L’insouciance,
parce que si j’avais en tête le brouhaha
et la tension permanente de ce camp,
ce camp, c’était ma normalité.
Je n'avais rien connu d'autre.
Jusqu'à ce que je quitte ce camp
et que j'arrive en France.
J’arrive en France à l’âge
de dix ans dans la ville de Niort.
Maupassant avait écrit : « L’exil est
assurément la plus terrible des peines
dont on peut frapper certains humains. »
Entre nous, il aurait pu ajouter :
« Surtout s’ils sont contraints
de s’installer dans les Deux-Sèvres. »
Mais ce n'est pas le sujet du jour.
La France sera pour moi le premier et le
seul pays à m’accorder une citoyenneté.
Et qui dit citoyenneté dit des droits.
Ce n’est pas un hasard
si je poursuis des études de droit
et si la protection des droits
des plus vulnérables
devient pour moi une véritable passion,
voire une obsession.
Et ce n’est pas un hasard non plus
si je décide de me spécialiser
en droit international des réfugiés.
Si j’ai choisi cette photo du passeport,
c’est parce que jusqu’à l’âge de 18 ans,
j’ai vécu sans nationalité,
sans carte d’identité et sans passeport.
Alors présenté comme ça,
ce storytelling est très beau à raconter.
C'est une histoire consolatrice
du sort des exilés.
Mais la réalité,
c’est que vous avez devant vous
ce soir une anomalie numérique.
Je suis une erreur dans la matrice.
Et vous allez vite comprendre pourquoi.
À l’heure où je vous parle,
un déplacé interne sur deux et un réfugié
sur trois vivent dans des camps.
Ce qui représente pas loin de 35 millions
de personnes dites « encampées ».
On parle de déplacé
quand on est à la recherche d’un refuge
à l’intérieur de son pays.
Et on parle de réfugié lorsqu’on cherche
un refuge à l’extérieur de son pays.
Mais alors,
où sont tous ces camps ?
Pourquoi sont-ils si invisibilisés ?
Et pourquoi sommes-nous toutes et tous
collectivement ignorants
du sort de ces exilés ?
Posez-vous la question.
Qui parmi vous serait capable de
placer ne serait-ce que cinq camps
sur une mappemonde ?
Pour comprendre
les dynamiques d’encampement,
il faut comprendre
les dynamiques de migration.
86% des personnes déracinées
à travers le monde
sont installées dans des pays voisins
de leur pays d’origine.
Et c’est précisément là que
se trouve l’essentiel des camps.
En Afrique, c'est 78% des réfugiés
qui vivent dans des camps.
En Asie, c'est près de 40% d'entre eux.
Et au Moyen-Orient,
c’est plus de 20% d’entre eux.
Mais ce qui détonne
le plus dans ces camps,
c’est la façon
dont ces lieux sont comme figés
dans une humanité qui, elle,
est en perpétuel mouvement.
La durée de vie moyenne d’un camp
est de 11,7 ans.
11,7 ans.
Vous l’aurez compris, l’enjeu des camps,
c’est leur pérennité.
Ce n’est pas tellement
le fait qu’ils existent
ou qu’ils fassent en soi partie du paysage
très complexe des migrations,
mais c’est le fait
qu’ils restent, qu’ils durent,
et qu’il deviennent des lieux de vie
à part entière.
Dans ce résumé que je viens de vous faire,
il y a l’histoire très concrète,
très réelle, de ma famille.
Mais cette histoire,
c’est celle de dizaines de millions
de personnes à travers le monde.
Amboko au Tchad, Kara Tepe en Grèce,
Mae La en Thaïlande, Zaatari en Jordanie
ou encore Dadaab au Kenya,
et tant d’autres encore.
Tous ces camps
posent la question cruciale des modèles de
sociétés dans lesquels nous voulons vivre
et des exigences d’hospitalité que nous
voulons, mais que nous devons, embrasser.
Parce que le camp est un échec.
Les camps sont
des lieux de mise à l’écart,
des lieux de gestion des indésirables,
des lieux où le mouvement est entravé,
et où la croisée des chemins
ne peut pas se réaliser.
Nous avons échoué.
Nous avons échoué, parce que si le camp
tente de sauver le présent des réfugiés,
il le fait sans assurer leur avenir.
Imaginez un instant
le gâchis que représentent
ces milliers de camps
installés à travers le monde
et dans lesquels des millions
de personnes sont condamnées à attendre,
à attendre, soit de pouvoir
rentrer chez eux,
soit de pouvoir être accueillis, soit de
pouvoir être installés dans un autre pays.
Pour illustrer mon propos,
vous avez ici un témoignage
d’un réfugié du camp de Gaoui, au Tchad.
Je le cite.
« C’est la pire des prisons.
Ici, c’est impossible
de se projeter dans l’avenir. »
Ce gâchis, on peut
le constater au présent.
Qu’en est-il de l’avenir ?
De notre avenir ?
En 2022, le Haut-Commissariat
des Nations unies pour les réfugiés
recense plus de 100 millions de personnes
déracinées à travers le monde.
Je pose la question :
si notre réponse a été l’encampement
pour 35 millions d’entre eux,
qu’adviendra-t-il des 250 millions
de réfugiés climatiques
que prévoient les Nations Unies
pour 2050 ?
2050, c'est demain.
Et c’est précisément pour penser le camp
comme une caractéristique de l’exil,
et non plus comme une solution à l’exil,
que j’ai fondé en 2019, à 27 ans,
l'Observatoire des camps de réfugiés.
Cet observatoire,
il naît suite à deux années de thèse
que je fais sur le droit applicable
sur les camps.
Projet doctoral lors duquel je fais
trois constats très frustrants.
Le premier :
aujourd’hui, personne
n’est capable de vous dire
combien de camps sont installés
à travers le monde.
Le deuxième constat :
les données qui existent
proviennent uniquement des acteurs
mandatés pour gérer ces camps,
ce qui pose un souci de transparence.
Troisième constat que je fais :
ces durées de vie
et le manque total d’alternative
à l’encampement
pour les populations qui sont installées
dans ces camps.
Et comme tout projet sorti de terre
avec beaucoup d’ambition,
l’Observatoire tente de répondre
à ces dysfonctionnements
à travers ses trois missions :
informer,
enquêter,
et sensibiliser sur les camps
à travers le monde.
Je dis souvent que j’ai commencé ce projet
avec zéro budget à investir
mais avec un budget café.
Très importants les cafés
quand vous entreprenez.
J’ai passé des mois à démarcher une à une
des personnes pour rejoindre ce projet.
Aujourd’hui, l’Observatoire, c’est 200
membres contributeurs et contributrices,
en France et à l'international, qui
remplissent cette mission d'informer,
d’enquêter et de sensibiliser
sur les camps à travers le monde.
Notre défi peut
se résumer à une question :
comment repenser
l’accueil et l’hospitalité
de façon à ce que ces camps
et le potentiel de ces camps
soient enfin considérés et humanisés ?
Ce potentiel, Il réside dans notre
capacité à faire passer ces humains.
d’un camp à une société.
Moi, j’ai pu passer
d’un camp à une société
et c’est grâce à ça, et seulement ça,
que j’ai pu me réaliser
et que je suis devant vous ce soir.
La question qui se pose désormais,
ce n’est pas de savoir
si les chemins sont tracés.
En réalité, là où les chemins
ne sont pas tracés, il faut les créer.
Et il est de la responsabilité
de chaque collectif, de chaque société,
d’offrir tous les embranchements
qui rendent possible
cette croisée des chemins.
Si je suis là devant vous ce soir,
c’est que je ne veux plus que mon histoire
soit considérée comme exceptionnelle,
mais qu’elle devienne la norme.
Et si je suis là devant vous ce soir,
c’est pour faire un pas
dans le monde des possibles.
Et si vous aussi vous faisiez
un pas vers ce monde ?
Et peut-être qu’en étant là ce soir,
vous avez déjà fait ce premier pas.
Je vous remercie.
(Applaudissements)